hi everyone this is professor mda
science and today i want to discuss the
three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator in another one of our videos
on rigorous quantum mechanics harmonic
oscillations permeate science as the low
energy behavior of many systems is
harmonic for example the quantum
harmonic oscillator allows us to study
the properties of systems ranging from
the motion of atoms in solids to the
behavior of light we have a whole series
of videos on the one-dimensional quantum
harmonic oscillator where we learn how
to calculate its eigenvalues and
eigenstates and we also have a whole
series on coherent states which provide
a quasi-classical view of the quantum
harmonic oscillator today we want to
discuss the quantum family oscillator
from yet another point of view which is
what happens when we go from one to
three dimensions to do so we're going to
exploit the properties of tensor
products this means that this video is
also a great resource for you to
practice tensor products which is really
useful because they feature in many many
different quantum systems so let's go
let's consider a particle moving in a
three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator
we call the state space of a particle
moving in three spatial dimensions v
and it's given by the tensor product of
the state spaces phi x v y and v z where
v x is the state space of a particle
moving in the x spatial dimension and
similarly for v y and v z
so as you can see to understand the
motion of particles in three spatial
dimensions we need to use the properties
of tensor product state spaces and if
you haven't seen the corresponding
videos yet i recommend that you check
them out first and continue with this
one afterwards
the hamiltonian h includes the kinetic
energy which is given by a term
proportional to the momentum squared
along the x direction a term
proportional to the momentum squared
along the y direction and the term
proportional to the momentum squared
along the z direction
and then we also have the potential
energy which depends on a quadratic term
in x
a quadratic term in y
and a quadratic term in z
the hamiltonian h acts on the full state
space v
and each of the terms in which we write
the hamiltonian also act on the full
state space v
however we see that the form that the
various terms take is rather simple
for example let's consider the first
term here
it is the kinetic energy of the particle
associated with momentum in the x
direction
this kinetic energy operator acts on the
full state space v but its action can be
separated into this part which acts on
vx only
this part which acts trivially on v y as
it is simply the corresponding identity
operator
and this part which again acts trivially
as the identity operator but now on vz
the only non-trivial part in this term
is the one acting on vx so we typically
simplify our notation to rewrite it like
this omitting the identity operators and
tensor product symbols
all other kinetic and potential energy
terms have a similar form with multiple
trivial parts so using the same
simplified notation we can write the
full hamiltonian as equal to the kinetic
energy along x
the kinetic energy along y and the
kinetic energy alongside
and then the potential energy along x
the potential energy along y and the
potential energy alongside
when we work with tensor product state
spaces we use this simple notation
whenever possible and if you've worked
with particles moving in three spatial
dimensions before it's very likely that
you'll have directly worked with this
latter simpler expression without
reference to the full original
expression up here
while this works fine for many types of
calculation it is important to keep in
mind that we're really working in a
tensor product state space as this can
become important to avoid potential
ambiguities
now to make sure that we become
comfortable with tensor product state
spaces we will combine the use of both
notations throughout the video
we can actually rewrite this hamiltonian
in another form that will prove really
convenient let's consider h
we can next group all the terms that act
non-trivially along the x direction
which are this kinetic energy term and
this potential energy term to end up
with this combined x-dependent term
and then the identity operators for the
y and z-directions
we can do the same for the terms acting
non-trivially along y to end up with
this identity
this y dependent term
and this other identity
and we can of course do the same for the
terms acting non-trivially along z to
end up with this identity this identity
and this z-dependent term
we now recognize this here as the
quantum harmonic oscillator hamiltonian
of a particle moving in the x-spatial
dimension
this here has a corresponding
hamiltonian of a particle moving in the
y spatial dimension and this here as a
corresponding hamiltonian of a particle
moving in the z spatial dimension
with this we can rewrite the hamiltonian
of a particle moving in a
three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator as the sum of a term that
only involves the hamiltonian of the
particle moving in the x-direction
plus the hamiltonian of the particle
moving along y
plus the hamiltonian of the particle
moving along z
using the simplified notation we
discussed in the previous slide we can
rewrite this as the sum of h x plus h y
plus h z
so what have we accomplished
this last expression shows that the
hamiltonian h of a particle moving in a
three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator is simply given by the sum of
the hamiltonians corresponding to the
particle moving in each of the three
dimensions separately
and this suggests that we will be able
to construct the full solution of the
three-dimensional problem simply by
combining the solutions of the
individual one-dimensional problems and
this is indeed what we're going to do in
the rest of this video
as always the solution of the quantum
harmonic oscillator involves the
solution of the eigenvalue equation
remember that for the three-dimensional
harmonic oscillator we work in the state
space v
and we write the eigenvalue equation as
h acting on psi
equal to e psi
where as usual these are the eigenvalues
and these are the eigen
states given the form of the hamiltonian
it will be useful to consider the
eigenvalue equations of the motion of
the particle along the individual
spatial directions
if we start with the state space vx of a
particle moving in the one-dimensional x
spatial direction then we have this
eigenvalue equation for the quantum
harmonic oscillator eigenvalue
we've already solved this problem of a
one-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator and from the corresponding
videos we know that the eigenvalues are
quantized and given by this expression
where nx is a non-negative integer
we can similarly work in state space v y
of a particle moving in the
one-dimensional y-spatial direction with
this eigenvalue equation
these quantized eigenvalues
and again the n y are non-negative
integers
and for v z we have the corresponding
eigenvalue equation
with the corresponding quantized
eigenvalues and the nz are still
non-negative integers
from the video on eigenvalues and
eigenstates of tensor product state
spaces linked in the description we know
that given the form of the hamiltonian
up here we can build the eigenvalues and
eigenstates of h from those of hx hy and
z
in particular the eigenstate psi is
given by the tensor product of the
eigenstates nx and y and nz
and the eigenvalue e
is given by the sum of the eigenvalues e
x e y and dz
and this is it we've solved the
eigenvalue equation of the
three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator by simply using our knowledge
of the solution of the one-dimensional
quantum harmonic oscillator
in the rest of the video we will explore
some interesting features of the
three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator
let's first consider the eigenvalues
remember that we've just figured out
that the eigenvalues e of the
three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator are given by the sum of e n x
e and y and e and z
given the expressions up here we can
rewrite to the eigenvalue e as equal to
the sum of this term proportional to
omega x
this term proportional to omega y and
this term proportional to omega z
the eigenvalues of the three-dimensional
harmonic oscillator are labeled by a
collection of three numbers n x and y
and z
and this means that we can label the
distinct eigenvalues of the
three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator with these three numbers
where nx and y and nz can each take any
non-negative integer value
to study the eigenstates it will first
prove convenient to consider the ladder
operators
let's start with vx from our videos on
the one-dimensional harmonic oscillator
we know that the lowering operator ax is
defined as this pre-factor
times the position operator plus this
other prefactor
times the momentum operator
the raising operator is the at joint a
dagger of the lowering operator and is
given by the corresponding term
proportional to position and the
negative of the corresponding term
proportional to momentum
these ladder operators are used
thoroughly in the study of the quantum
harmonic oscillator for example we use
them to figure out the allowed
eigenvalues but now we are interested in
their action on the eigenstates
the lowering operator acting on an
energy eigenstate gives another energy
eigenstate where we've removed one
quantum of energy
conversely the racing operator acting on
the same energy eigenstate gives another
energy eigenstate where we've added one
quantum of energy
this is a quick refresher on ladder
operators and for a full description of
these ideas you should check out the
videos in the description
for our purposes today the important
thing is that when we work in v y we can
define an analogous lowering operator
and analogous raising operator
and when we work in visit we can define
an analogous lowering operator
and an analogous racing operator as well
from the video on tensor product state
spaces we know how to extend the action
of these ladder operators to the full
state space
as an example consider the operator ax
identity y identity z
acting on an energy eigenstate n x n y
and z
from the video on tensor products we
know that each operator acts only on the
state from its original space so ax acts
on nx to get this
then the identity acts on ny to
trivially get ny back
and finally this identity acts on nz to
trivially get nz back
in the simplified notation for apparatus
we would simply write this as ax acting
on the tensor product state
giving this new tensor product state
although we only write a x we implicitly
understand that we also have the
identities in v y and v z
so again the simplified notation is more
convenient but we need to be sure that
we know what we're doing
the ladder operators are important
because we can use them to build the
eigen states
in vx we have that the eigen state nx is
equal to this prefactor
times the application of the raising
operator nx times
on the ground state
now remember that the ground state is
the state associated with the lowest
energy eigenvalue and is such that the
action of ax on it kills the state
in vy the energy eigenstate ny is given
by the corresponding action of the
rating operator on the ground state and
in vz the energy eigenstate nz is also
obtained by the application of the
corresponding raising operator on the
ground state
if we now move to the center product
state space v of the three-dimensional
harmonic oscillator we've determined
earlier that the eigenstates are given
by the tensor product of the eigenstates
in v x v y
and v z
now the expression for this eigenstate
is rather long so bear with me
using these expressions up here we first
get this combined pre-factor
then the application of ax a total of nx
times the application of a y a total of
n y times and the application of azit
for a total of nz times
all of this acting on the ground state
of the three-dimensional oscillator
and these are the eigen states of the
three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator as built from the rating
operators
just like we do for operators we can use
simpler notation to describe tensor
product states such as these
let's take the eigenstate nx and y and z
a common simplification is the emission
of the tensor product symbol
another simplification typically used is
the emission of the sub-indices
indicating the original state space to
which the states belong to
in this case the order of the terms
indicates the state space of origin in
other words we understand that the first
kit comes from vx the second from v y
and the third from v z
yes another simplification is to group
these together into a single kit where
the various labels are separated by
commas
you'll encounter all of these
conventions and again it is essential
that you always remember what you are
really dealing with tensor product
states
using this simple notation together with
the simple notation for operators we can
rewrite the eigenstates of the
three-dimensional quantum harmonics
later as equal to this pre-factor
times the action of ax that of a y and
that of a z on the ground state
sticking with eigenstates we're now
going to look at the position
representation or to put it another way
at the wave functions of the
three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator if we start in the vx state
space remember that for a one
dimensional harmonic oscillator the wave
function associated with energy
eigenstate nx is labeled as psi nx of x
and is given by the usual bracket
between the position eigen states and
the energy eigenstate we are interested
in
in the video on the quantum harmonic
oscillator eigenstates we show that this
wave function can be written as this
prefactor
multiplied by a polynomial of order in x
called a hermit polynomial multiplied by
a gaussian
as you can imagine if we look at v y we
have an analogous expression for the
wave function in terms of the
corresponding prefactor
the hermit polynomial and the gaussian
and if we look at vz we also get the
wave function again as equal to this
prefactor the hermit polynomial and the
gaussian
we can now look at the state space v of
the three-dimensional oscillator
we're going to call the wave function
psi n x and y and z and it is a function
of the three variables x y z
it is given by the bracket between the
position basis states
and the energy eigenstates that we're
interested in
from the video on tensor products we
know that we can calculate this bracket
by grouping together the objects in the
same state spaces making up the tensor
product state space
in vx we get this bracket we then need
to multiply this by the corresponding
bracket in v y and by the corresponding
bracket in v z
we can now construct the full wave
function by using the wave functions
along the individual one-dimensional
spaces above
for the scalar products in vx we get the
psi and x wave function for the scalar
product of v y we get the psi and y wave
function and for the scalar products in
v z we get the psi and z wave function
and this is it
this is the wave function of the energy
eigenstates of the three-dimensional
quantum harmonic oscillator
it is simply the product of the wave
function of a one-dimensional oscillator
along x with a one-dimensional
oscillator along y
with a one-dimensional oscillator along
z
now a word of caution
notation could be somewhat confusing so
let's make sure that we really do
understand it
when we write psi here with three
sub-indices we mean the wave function of
the three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator
when we write psi with a single
sub-index for example this one here we
mean the wave function of the
one-dimensional harmonic oscillator and
in this case it corresponds to a
one-dimensional harmonic oscillator
along the z-axis
okay so these are the wave functions
for the one-dimensional harmonic
oscillator we spend some time plotting
them
unfortunately it isn't possible to fully
plot the eigenfunctions of the three
dimensionals later as we would need a
four-dimensional space to do so
but we could certainly visualize them
along the different spatial axes where
they essentially look like they're
one-dimensional counterparts so i
encourage you to check out the video on
the eigenfunctions of the
one-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator for a reminder of what they
look like
let's finish with a brief summary this
is the hamiltonian of a
three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator
in this expression i spell it out in its
full glory in terms of tensor products
of operators associated with one
dimensional harmonic oscillators along
the x y and z directions
for example this term here is a term
that contains a kinetic energy of the
particle moving in the x direction and
only acts trivially along the y and z
directions
when we work with tensor product state
spaces we tend to simplify our notation
if we can do so without introducing any
ambiguity
in this case the simple notation is
given by this hamiltonian down here
the hamiltonians in either notation show
that the three-dimensional quantum
harmonic oscillator is essentially a
simple sum of three hamiltonians
corresponding to the separate
one-dimensional motion of the particle
in each of the x y and z dimensions
we've seen that this simple form for the
hamiltonian means that it is very easy
to construct the energy eigenvalues and
eigen states of the three-dimensional
harmonic oscillator from those of the
one-dimensional oscillator
the energy eigenvalues of the
three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator are simply given by the sum
of the energy eigenvalues of a
one-dimensional harmonic oscillator
along the x-direction the y-direction
and the z-direction
this longer expression shows the
explicit form of these energy
eigenvalues
we can also easily build the energy's
eigenstates they are simply given by the
tensor products of the energy
eigenstates of the individual
one-dimensional oscillators along x y
and z
explicitly we can write them as
proportional to the action of the
raising operators on the ground state
and this here again shows the same
expression for the eigen states but
using the simpler notation that we
typically encounter when working with
tensor product states
finally we've also found that the wave
function of the three-dimensional
quantum harmonic oscillator is simply
given by the product of the wave
functions of three one-dimensional
harmonic oscillators along x along y and
along z
so overall the form of the hamiltonian
of the three-dimensional quantum
harmonic oscillator means that we can
find its solutions by simply combining
the known solutions of various
one-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillators
we've just seen how the
three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator is a relatively
straightforward extension of its
one-dimensional counterpart the energy
eigenvalues are simply the sum of the
eigenvalues of the one-dimensional
oscillators along the cartesian
directions and the energy eigenstates
are simply the tensor products of the
energy eigenstates of one-dimensional
oscillators along the cartesian
directions this may appear really simple
but actually it provides us with a
really powerful foundation from which to
study a range of really interesting
properties that emerge when we have an
isotropic quantum harmonic oscillator i
therefore encourage you to check out the
video on the degeneracies of the
three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator or the videos where we look
at the isotropic three-dimensional
oscillator at the central potential and
as always if you liked the video please
subscribe